open-source warfare is one of these
things that's taking place right now in
the 21st century where you have a wide
variety of actors out there war is not
just limited to large states just like
with the software industry on open
source it's not just limited to the
control of a couple large companies but
rather you have multiple players out
there so for example in the military
robotics realm it's not just the US
military that's building and using these
system 43 other countries are building
and using them and they're from large
states like a China or Russia to a
weaker States like a Pakistan Iran's
working on them but the other thing is
that it's not just States it's non-state
actors so in terms of non-state actors
you've had for example Hezbollah during
its war with Israel in 2007 it wasn't
just a state taking on an on state
organization but it was also
revolutionary because both sides used
unmanned drones against each other you
have jihadi websites where you can
remotely detonate an IED sitting at your
home computer and what we're getting out
here is that multiple players can enter
this realm for a thousand dollars you
can build a drone thats basically has
the same capabilities that the US
military Raven drone has this is the
handheld drone that the soldiers use in
Iraq four thousand dollars you can build
it with a do-it-yourself kit and so what
you have is sort of the flattening of
the realm of war and that has to scare
us in a certain way because it means
that these trends of the empowerment of
smaller and smaller organizations but
all the way down to individuals can
continue and one of the people that I
interviewed for the book was Richard
Clark who was the government official
who famously warned about 911 before it
happened asked him about you know where
do you see this trend of robotics new
technology and conflict going and he
said it's not just the concern over all
these organizations starting to use
robotics and how it empowers them how an
al-qaeda can do a lot more things with a
draw
own that it could without it's also that
it might cause new sparks of conflict
neo-luddite isn't people who are so
upset about change that they take out
violence to try and prevent change
another way of putting it is he saw the
future as being a mix between al-qaida
2.0 and the Unabomber
as dr. Phil would say you can't be in
denial and that's where we're at right
now we are in denial the sands are
shifting underneath us and that's true
whether you were talking about large
meta trends like we're finally starting
to accept for example that global
warming is happening but we have to take
it to the next step what are the
implications of that on international
security so what does it mean not just
that the Arctic is melting but what does
the world look like when you have
competition over those resources the
same thing when it comes to these new
technologies we act as if robotics are
just mere science fiction well we have
5000 drones in the air and 12,000
unmanned ground systems and this is
right now where we're at right now a
three-star Air Force general said to me
look where the trends are taking us very
soon is to tens of thousands of robots
fighting in our conflicts that's the
reality right now and so you can either
have your head in the sand or you can
face it and so you've got to figure out
all the challenging questions that
surround it in terms of your politics in
terms of your law in terms of your
ethics you have to catch up to it
because otherwise we're going to repeat
the same mistake that we made and past
revolutions and pastimes of great
transition the atomic bomb would be a
great example of that where it was
something that we kept in the realm of
science fiction in fact the atomic bomb
was something that HG Wells first came
up in and a story called world set free
and the scientists of the day said no no
this could never happen you could never
have a bomb that was made out of
radioactive materials and used a chain
reaction as he called it that's crazy
well guess what it did happen and in
fact his story was inspirational to the
people behind the Manhattan Project but
it was like Pandora's box we only waited
to deal with it until after the fact in
all the ways that it was going to ripple
out on our politics in our society the
same thing is happening right now with
robotics and we often sort of laugh at
it because you know what it's things
like the Terminator of Battlestar
Galactica and I'm not saying here that
you have to worry about the Governor of
California showing up at your
door that's not the robotics revolution
that's ongoing it's a revolution in
warfare it's a revolution that's having
a ripple effect out on to how we fight
and who fights at the most fundamental
level